crazy five team trade in the br app  let's talk about it so the los angeles  lakers would get kyrie irving pat bev  and dario sorry sons get kd and bojon  the new york knicks get donovan mitchell  and cam thomas  and who do the nets get after losing kd  and kyrie will they get back bridges  tallyhorn tucker and campaign with five  first-round picks  what  there is no way in hell this is an  acceptable package for the nets to get  back no and then the utah jazz get  westbrook a bunch of players and some  picks [ __ ] they got more than what the  nets got let us know what you guys think  about this five team deal man cause it's  gonna be stressed out